say the line buck one pieces alabaster
is the best manga experience I've had in
my entire life I'm serious
like I knew this was going to be good
and there's been plenty of tension and
suspense building over the course of the
last few arcs
certainly enough to take a line little
Irish feet but I didn't know it was
going to be this good like this is
advanced good and over the course of
this video I will try to communicate to
you all just how the best the alabasta
arc was for me someone entirely new to
this series over the last three videos
I've covered the introduction to the
straw hat crew explored their pasts and
explained the circumstances that have
been building but today it all comes to
a bursting point in this arc the
culmination of over a hundred chapters a
phenomenal storytelling character
writing and world building I'm totally
not Marc and these are my first
impressions my thoughts on and review
for the greatest arc one piece is
offered up to this point this is the
writing masterclass the phenomenal
alabasta arc
one of the main differences between this
and the other arcs prior can be seen
first and foremost in its length it's a
long one sure but first I want to
impress upon you just how long this was
and how stupid I was when reading it the
arc itself spans 62 chapters which
translates to about six and a half
volume zuv manga this is by far the most
I've ever had to read in a given week
for a single video and because I'm dumb
I left myself with only two days to read
the manga before I needed to write this
script needless to say I did it but my
hands are still healing from the paper
cuts
however the point I'm trying to make is
that this story is long and great so in
order for me to break down my
impressions and to explain how I think
this arc pulls off its greatness I'm
gonna need to break this story down into
chronological sections to make this even
remotely possible for me to analyze and
present to you and so with this
disclaimer out of the way let's talk
about the first section the world and
set up in a nutshell the story of the
alabasta our covers the kingdoms
rebellion against their king and how the
Barrett works who led by crocodile has
influenced the politics in the region in
order to achieve what he wants it kicks
things off as the straw hat crew we've
been following for the last hundred or
so chapters finally begin to near the
kingdom it's a fascinating tale of
friendship war betrayal and loyalty but
for me personally this is the moment
when peace stuff being just a great
manga and became for me a true epic I
think everyone needs to experience for
themselves in order to truly appreciate
it through reading one piece over the
last month I think I've discovered the
secret to owners writing how he always
seems to catch me by surprise he sets up
way too many things for me to even
attend to keep track of in my mind and
that's not a complaint if anything
that's precisely what makes his world
feel so alive in chaotic all the time
typically when I'm reading a story I can
identify the main two or three points a
writer is using to create a subversion
later but with Oda he keeps throwing
things at me to remember and to keep in
mind that eventually I have to say to
myself alright Oda you win take me where
you want to go which is super fun for me
and the means with which this arc opens
is really interesting as it provides
intrigue and suspense for us the
audience without any conflict right away
kicking things off we get a scene where
in mr. to one of the main Barrow quirks
agents working for crocodile gets picked
up by a Luffy in the gang at this
in the story they're suspected to be
dead and at this point mr. to is a
complete unknown to them - which is a
fantastic example of dramatic irony
which means that we the audience know
more than the characters do right now in
this case we know that Luffy and the
gang want to avoid this guy and we know
that mr. tube would want to apprehend
this crew - had he known about them and
so watching as they make friends is both
funny and nerve-wracking as in the last
arc Sanji managed to get the straw hat
crew the element of surprise in the
first place but during this interaction
with mr. - as a party trick he reveals
the devil fruit powers to transform into
anyone he touches however once he leaves
it quickly becomes apparent to the crew
just how lucky they really were learning
about mr. twos identity and so in an
attempt to stay one step ahead of him
the gang elect to tie a piece of cloth
unto their left arms to identify
themselves to each other if he ever
becomes a problem in the future
now you see what I mean they haven't
even arrived at alabasta yet and we
already have so many things to keep
track of and this story doesn't slow
down either as once we do touch down we
are introduced to captain smoker who's
already there looking for Luffy and we
are introduced for the first time to
this ace character from the end of the
last dark
he is an entire kettle of fish into an
of himself so I'll try to cover what I
thought about him succinctly we learned
that his real name is pork ass D ace and
that he's Luffy's brother which raises
all sorts of questions for me like are
there no surnames in this world what's
the connection between him Luffy and
Goldie Roger
maybe he's his father but I feel like
that's maybe too obvious we also learned
that ace has a demo free power that
pretty much makes him the Human Torch
which makes him objectively the coolest
character now in the entire series
essentially his character is here to
offer Luffy a spot with the pirate crew
he's a part of whitebeard's pirates and
to give Luffy this piece of paper with
nothing on it see what I mean about this
act giving us so many things to remember
and think about like ace mentioned in
the last act that he was looking for
Blackbeard then when he realized that he
was long gone
he decided to look for Luffy like is
time-traveled involved in this I have
too many things to consider with this
character I know at this point that I'm
trying to remember everything which is a
fool's errand as I have at this point no
way of telling which piece of
information is pertinent to this story
or what will be pertinent later and so
for the first time in the series so far
I have to relinquish control of my brain
to Oda one piece you have beaten me but
back to the story the heart of the arc
itself comes in the form of princes
Vivi's devotion to her kingdom its
people and the desire she has to stop
this senseless fighting and once these
opening pleasantries are taken care of
three separate storylines are set in
motion in three different areas of
alabasta which Oda uses as an excuse to
teach us the geography of the country
and by the time we're finished with this
arc you will have a full comprehensive
understanding of where everything is in
this country the number one priority on
Vivi's list at this point is to prevent
the rebellion and so she elects that the
best course of action is to not flee to
the palace but instead to try and reason
with the rebel leader in an oasis called
yuba across a vast desert this is great
fundamentally as we needed a concrete
goal to aim for as an audience but it
also sheds more light on Vivi's
character she's smart but she's also
incredibly brave and determined and so
just before the crew began making their
way to yubi Vivi sends kuru her duck
monster thing on a long journey across
another desert to relay a message to her
father directly at the palace
the contents being proof of crocodiles
true identity using information she and
Ingram gathered during their time
undercover as mr. aide and miss
Wednesday once again this is another
example of the seeds oda planted like 50
chapters ago now bears fruit for the
story in making it that much more rich
and finally to give context as to why
mr. too had been traveling back to
alabasta it appears that all the
high-ranking individuals among the
criminal syndicate known as the barrel
quirks had been told to gather for the
first time to meet the leader known to
them as mr. zero which they learned
obviously to be crocodile himself this
is initially shocking as crocodile has
been portrayed thus far in the series as
aneroid figure in the area of alabasta
seen as a savior to the country and with
the reveal of this plan we learn a great
deal about crocodile as a character he's
charismatic confident does not accept
failure and is incredibly manipulative
he reveals that he's not interested in
money or status but instead military
might revealing that he can obtain
something that will give him absolute
power once he gains access to it and
with that each high-ranking member of
the barrack works is given a specific
mission they are told that once their
missions are all complete the kingdom
will explode ending the meeting by
saying that his utopia starts tomorrow
at 7:00 in the morning this scene is
great but as I said there's tons of
characterization here for crocodile in
this section croc naturally at this
point is aware that the straw hat crew
is alive and more than likely in
alabasta right now with the princess
this naturally comes as a big surprise
to mr. too and so with that information
they all become aware that their
secondary mission now is to prevent
princess Vivi from meeting with the
rebel forces as they have a vested
interest in making this rebellion happen
and all of this information is really
compelling in all the rest of it but the
sea itself becomes all the more better
when mr. three reveals himself from the
shadows offering his services once again
however in a demonstration of his
ruthlessness and power croc sucks the
moisture from mr. three's body before
throwing him into a massive banana
crocodile pit it's horrific scene but a
fantastic one that really really sells
us on crocodiles character and the
progression of these three plot threads
watching them develop complicate and
intertwine left me sincerely with my jaw
on the floor as I watched Oda juggle and
keep track of so many different moving
parts at once
I like to pretend that he was spending
sleepless nights constructing this with
cork boards and connecting string
all over his office because this Ark is
nuts and one storytelling mechanic Odin
loves to use at nauseam is that of the
flashback and I don't say that in a
disparaging way either oldest goal is to
make this world feel real and lived in
and in order for that to be the case
there needs to be history and in a
similar fashion as the rest of the
series this Ark is the recipient of its
very own flashback sequences the first
concern the childhood of Princess Vivi
and how she came to befriend the now
leader of the rebel forces in an
individual called Klose
and his father toto it's enlightening
it's heartwarming watching as Cota saves
her life and it more importantly gives
us a glimpse at the Kings personality in
nature admittedly I thought he looked a
little too much like fire lord ozai from
the last airbender not to be the most
evil man in the series but it turns out
he's a super ridiculously kind and wise
men making his framing at the hands of
crocodile all the more infuriating and
sad elevating the character of croc once
again in her eyes as someone who needs
to be dealt with soon and as it happens
in the world of one piece there are
mechanisms with which to control and
manipulate the weather and that's
essentially what the rebels led by Koza
are looking to overthrow the king for
thinking that he is causing this drought
or abstaining from calling upon more
rain for the kingdom due to him being
unkind or something which as we discover
thanks to flashback is most definitely
not the case but what makes this cozy
character as interesting as he is comes
in the form of his father who the gang
encounter once they reached the now
almost entirely deserted oasis of Yuba
where Koza is a radical rebel for
justice looking to overthrow what he
believes to be an evil cold King toto
his father is an incredibly loyal kind
and hard-working men still keeping his
faith in the king trying to do his best
and keeping the promise he made to him
in building a town in yuba and in
meeting this lovely but now starving
overworked old man I get another glimpse
at what makes this story of one piece so
special to me despite the tail being
grand in scope and Bish's in its telling
and masterful in its execution Oda
always seems to find time to create
pockets of story that are beautifully
intimate between one or two characters
the one I'm referring to in this
instance is Luffy's helping of the old
man dig for water trying to keep the
Oasis alive long into the night it
offers a window into the humble kind old
man's life but it's also a small shared
moment that reminds me why I love Luffy
and the writing of this series Luffy who
had been notorious for wasting food and
water
throughout the story no treats this
water uba's water with respect and care
because he knows how much this means to
the old man he knows where it came from
and he knows what it represents which is
hope for the future of this country it's
a wonderfully intimate in subtle
metaphor that encapsulates this entire
story in the most precious of ways that
sincerely brought a tear to my eye and
what's most impressive about this is we
haven't even really started yet the
suspense the more time we spend in a
massive area of alabasta the more it
reveals to us its customs cultures
geographical formations and wildlife
which all play important roles in not
only creating funny moments to help with
the pacing but their inclusions and
mentioning 'he's also facilitate
callbacks and surprises later in the
story to push the plot forward for
instance the clothing keeps the gang
from overheating in the desert Vivi
however doesn't mind the heat at all as
this is her home the massive deserts
that cover the country act also as
obstacles that only uses to great effect
this isn't like any other story where we
can just cost and the gang is suddenly
where they want to be oh no if there's a
river they have to provide a means with
which to cross it if there's a desert
they have to make sure that they have
supplies and as I'm sure you're starting
to appreciate right now this makes the
story feel all the more impressive and
detailed to me and not to mention adds
to the suspense of the occasion which
isn't helped as once they arrive and
finish helping the old man in yuba they
all immediately realized that not only
are the rebels not where they thought
they were but they are also getting
ready to march on the palace tomorrow
the same day the Utopia plan is
happening with crock which the gang
don't know about yet but we do see how
this dramatic irony is slipping into the
story to create even more tension for us
the reader specifically and so instead
of journeying all the way back to the
rebels at the beginning Luffy decides
that attacking the source of the trouble
in pain is the best course of action and
after a particularly heated scene
between Luffy and Vivi it's decided that
croc is going down he's their new target
and this is where things really start to
pick up and get interesting for me and
let me tell you it doesn't slow down
from this point onwards at all in
response to learning Crocs true Moto's
via Vivi's message the king orders his
military leaders to gather his forces
and march on Raine base where croc is
stationed and what's great about this
scene is that it gives the King another
chance to endear himself to us for
despite knowing that the rebels are
going to be here soon
he still instructs his defenses to leave
the past where he is
hack the real source of danger he wants
only to protect his people he doesn't
care about his palace and what's more as
this also builds more tension as the
straw hats arrive in Crocs town which
leads nicely into one of my favorite
sequences in the arc as once they arrive
in the town oda introduces a nice little
game of cat and mouse between smoker his
subordinates and the straw hat crew
essentially they end up getting
separated but in the end plan
reconvening back at the casino where
crocs hideout is however this doesn't go
to plan and do largely to luffy's lack
of preparation and respect for how
powerful croc really is most of the
straw hats and smoker himself get
captured by croc and miss all Sunday in
a cage within the base now I call this
particular section of the story this
suspense as this is the section where
essentially all the plans for the forces
of good flight out the window in a fiery
failure the likes of which really made
me stress out while I was reading
essentially the gang gets captured
Vivi's friend and loyal military
commander arrives to save her but gets
taken up by missile Sunday Vivi gets
thrown in front of croc the King now
can't advances army without his other
military leader it's all going crocs way
which makes us despair for anything good
to happen in favor of the group but
before I get into what might be my
favorite secrets of the entire story I
think it's important to point out
something I didn't like and while this
is really the only thing I didn't like
in the entire story I thought it worth
mentioning in the interest of
transparency around this point were
greeted by another flashback
demonstrating some of Kouzes past and
also an audience he had with the king
himself instead of having a normal
conversation like humans about specific
things and giving specific answers the
two decide to play the let's speak in
vague ambiguous ways games so that one
of us will leave the conversation with
the wrong impression of the other Koza
asks the King a question after questions
spiraling further into misunderstanding
as the King gives vague responses if he
had gone into any detail to explain his
situation his circumstances and his own
worries there would have been no
confusion but he doesn't and as we are
aware becomes the leader of the rebel
forces this is the only thing in the arc
I didn't like and it sort of created
artificial tension which is a shame
considering the entire arc does a
fantastic job of creating real tension
everywhere else but back to the Bond
villain praça da scenario and possibly
my favorite scene in the entire series
so far his plan is fully explained as
all great supervillain plans are but
this time with a twist
and this is what makes crock a
wonderfully fun and playful villain he
sees two things that VP loves and forces
her to choose between them giving her
the chance to make the impossible
journey home across the desert and water
to try to stop the rebellion or to save
her friends as they are trapped in a
cage with the water level in the room
rising and the only key is apparently
inside the stomach of one of the several
crocodiles in his possession sort of a
Sophie's Choice situation but that's not
even the good part you see just as croc
in this all Sunday are about to leave
Restaurant Allah crap calls the snail
phone and this is when we realized that
Sanjay and chopper are both still free
and they have thought of a plan to help
their situation croc recognizes the
voice is the same one that was at little
garden and to put the cherry on top of
this cake Sanji refers to himself in the
call protecting his true identity going
under the alias of mr. prince because he
fully intends on rescuing the princess I
laughed out loud reading that and it was
made all the more satisfying by just how
awful and not at all according to plan
the day has gone so far so it's
incredibly cathartic on one hand to see
crocked ego get tested and he now has
some of his own medicine thrown into his
face and what's more is as chopper
distracts croc outside something even
more ridiculously awesome happens
alright so we find out that this key
that they had been trying to get out of
the croc isn't even the real key but let
me tell you I did expect him to get out
but I never would have guessed in a
million years what happens next so Sanji
begins beating off the banana crocs
until one of them spits out this ball
it's mister friggin three he put himself
into this little wax ball to protect
himself when the Crocs came to eat him
after crocodile threw him to them in the
first place and he makes a wax key to
get them out how crazy is that and
what's even more awesome now is that
luffy finally has this opportunity to
clobber croc but let me tell you this
didn't go at all like I was expecting it
to I mentioned in my last video that I
really didn't like king waffle and on
top of him largely being uninteresting
to me he also didn't offer Luffy any
challenge whatsoever and throughout the
entire series so far Luffy has only
really been taken to his limit by one
person
Don Creek but this battle he has with
croc and I used the war
battle loosely when I first read through
us really set an entirely different tone
in this story for me the likes of which
I hadn't experienced so far in one piece
the crocodile character is one of the
first of the seven warlords Luffy has
ever faced and the difference in League
becomes immediately apparent as he uses
his sand powers to evade every single
one of luffy's attacks he's able to
summon sandstorms quicksand and even
demonstrates that he can suck the life
out of living beings by dehydrating
their bodies he proves to us that there
is an entirely new level of foe out
there and the panels that come from this
battle are honestly horrific the most
graphic being Luffy's impalement on the
hook of croc all the enthusiasm
confidence and strength in the world
couldn't save him he didn't even really
stand a chance and with the gang no
heading towards the kingdom thinking
that luffy has croc handled the little
pirates limp corpse is thrown into some
quicksand before croc makes his way to
the palace himself now that's how you
create suspense what an outrageously
compelling sequence I think we should go
without saying that I was completely
blown away at this point
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
join the airforce
the payoff I called this section to pay
off not because this represents the
climax necessarily but because this is
the section where every single bit of
time orders invested into the character
development of the straw hat crew pays
off and then some and much like the rest
of the series this is spectacularly
paced and orchestrated no point that I
feel like something was boring or
lacking everything was pitch perfect as
a straw hat crew made their way to the
capital in their attempt to stop the
Ayden's of the barrel works the
rebellion and ultimately prevent the
country's collapse made all the more
tense as once again utilizing dramatic
irony
we know that Luffy has failed hard while
the rest of the cast are none the wiser
but if I'm being completely honest here
the feeling of camaraderie and
togetherness this arc and really the
rest of this series has fostered creates
this incredibly unique atmosphere and as
the gang triumphantly rides into the
city with their plan in mind
it feels both epic and fun especially
when this marks the first time the
forces of good have outsmarted the
forces of the Baroque works in this arc
on their first attempt without replacing
each individual member of the straw hat
crew like chess pieces to manifest the
single most interesting fight sequences
he possibly could you see at the time
that they arrived at the capital it's
been made known to us that the forces of
the barrack work have as I alluded to
earlier being given specific roles to
carry out and on top of that
lesser members have also infiltrated the
army of the king and the rebels
essentially they've got their fingers on
tons of pie but that's okay it seems as
the straw hat crew split up as they now
got a plan to deal with each individual
agent or group of agents in some cases
which offers up just a bunch of really
fun matchups and scenarios not to
mention fight scenes and there are four
of these fights in total there's Bruce
op and chopper versus mr. form this
Christmas there's Sanji versus mr. to
Nami verse miss double finger and
finally there's or oversee mr. won each
fight sequence is given its own space
and room to breathe and what's more is
that they also ascertain a particular
pecking order within the group
themselves in terms of who among them is
the most capable and weakest based on
their foes and on top of that they each
offer a different tone to the story to
avoid things becoming too stale and
while this section is mainly concerned
with the fight scenes conflicts might be
a better word to use as this is a team
effort and Vivi is very much involved in
this struggle too albeit not directly in
battle but instead the opposite trying
to prevent the battle itself from
happening
between the kingdom and its people and
despite being put into the perfect
circumstance to prevent this battle from
even happening croc arrives and you
guested ruins it so before I get into
these battles that I mentioned earlier I
want to make mention of two things
obviously mr2 is floating around with
the ability now to transform into any
one of her friends and he does so by
trying to apprehend Vivi pretending to
be loose up armed even with some of the
cloth around his left arm
however after he calls kuru bird Vivi
suspicions are piqued and when asked to
prove his identity he shows the cloth on
his arm but what we didn't know as an
audience was that there was a part two
to that plan of theirs from the
beginning they marked themselves with an
X onto the cloth to show people to prove
who they are which honestly is a real
art thing I think and naturally because
he didn't show this X she runs and this
is when the battles take place both with
the rebellion and with the fight scenes
in the series so far and I feel like a
broken record repeating this but this
story keeps getting better these aren't
just whatever bland filler fights these
service the characters and obviously
this story too but what I love most
about this section is how its structured
it doesn't at all feel like we're
waiting for Luffy to show up or like
this is sort of stalling on behalf of
Oda and that's because the goal that's
always being to stop the fighting and
rebellion in alabasta and so that's
precisely what the others are doing in
their individual fights right now sure
Luffy fighting croc will play a role
later I'm sure
but all of these individual battles have
massive importance and implications
within the story if these fights don't
end in the favor of the straw hats it's
over and what's more is were made to
feel that with the time this section is
given to breathe in Dragon Ball you'd be
hard-pressed to find a long stretch of
chapters that don't at least show Goku
warts heck even when Goku's out of
commission Toriyama would often switch
back to him healing in a tank or
something but in this story Luffy is
treated as if he's no longer a factor
like he's been taken care of and that's
because what's happening now is more
important than him this shows a
tremendous confidence in the story and
writing and it's one of the reasons why
this series works so friggin well for me
it's not a one note one character let's
show they're a team they're our family
and having gone on this journey with
them for all of these chapters I can't
help but feel part of that too it's a
great sensation unlike anything I've
ever experienced reading a manga
who's up in chopper versus mr. four and
miss Christmas I thought the idea of
combining the forces of the two most
uncertain characters in the crew was a
fantastic one that really helped to
establish the tension and struggle of
the occasion within this fight scene
right away with both characters looking
to the other to help come up with a plan
or to run for help it not only made for
some hilarious moments implementing some
of moose Ops trademark running away
tactics and deceased but also
demonstrated for both characters their
resolve and courage when faced with what
turned out to be a massively powerful
foes ending on what I thought was a
brilliantly heartfelt note as Busiek
goes through hell and back to provide
Chopra the opening to deliver the final
blow and they also really sort of like
the mechanisms that Chopper introduces
to fight scenes
he eats this Rumble ball and it gives
Oda an excuse to do something clever
when he uses it to enhance brain
function for chopper and the ideas he
comes up with in this fight really did
take me by surprise of all the fights
that take place before the main one this
one might actually be my favorite not to
suggest that the others aren't great
also I think one aspect that this fight
had over the others that makes it an
unfair comparison is that I had a team
dynamic that we don't often see as well
as one of the biggest underdogs in the
crew which is always fun to watch Sanji
first mister to the role Sanji plays in
this series is honestly phenomenal of
all the characters in the straw hat crew
both he and Xaro in terms of demeanor
are the most similar I think they are
both extremely competent loyal and cocky
but the aspects that make Sanji distinct
are always highlighted by Oda which only
serves to make me enjoy him more for
example after princess Vivi discovers
that the fake who suffers actually mr.
to in disguise Sanji as if his princess
senses were tingling swoops in to save
the day and it's moments like that with
his very tongue-in-cheek mr. Prince
character that made this Eric feel all
the more fun for me and if I'm being
honest I don't really like characters
like Roshi from Dragon Ball or Brock
from Pokemon because they always seem
very would note and boring
not to mention predictable but with the
Sanji character Oda combines his
confidence and his appreciation for the
girls of this world to create a prince
charming wannabe take on him that is
both funny and appropriate for the
setting and what's more as that Sanji's
fight with mr. tooth provides him the
most interesting challenge as mr. two
can become women in his life like Nami
requiring him to face his greatest
weakness and to find means around that
which he eventually does overall I
really enjoyed this fight scene full of
character and light-hearted humor Nami
versus Miss double finger and on the
topic of humor it's time for the Nami
fight scene one thing I wanted more than
anything for nominees character was for
her to become more involved with the
battles her character has always been
more inclined to think first steal
second and then fight if need be but
with the situations in the Grand Line
becoming more and more intense I'm glad
Otis saw fit to have OSAP develop for
her her very own special weapon what I
didn't expect was how funny and
disastrous it would be for her naturally
it's her first time using this new
weapon and the instructions manual that
OSAP wrote up for her had an
overemphasis on party tricks needless to
say but watching Nami try and figure out
how this staff worked in order to best
miss double finger was a treat in the
half
and given that she's a navigator for her
weapon to utilize aspects navigators
have to keep in mind like weather
conditions was a really nice touch and
while this might not be the most epic of
fights it certainly provided a leg up
for Nami as a character to stay up there
with the rest of them and it was damn
funny which really helped with the story
facing Zorro first mr. one Sora's fight
against mr. one is another great matchup
not only because he has a body made
entirely of steel blades and thus makes
a great match for Zorro but it's also
interesting as my editor had to point
out to me that in mr. Wong's very first
debut scene in the manga the autumn on a
pea that accompanies that panel is a
sound associated with metal and blades
so if I was looking out for that I could
have in a sense discovered the nature of
his power before even really being shown
it which is a really unusual but very
cool detail to add to your story with
that said however the main meat and
potatoes of this sequences basically
Zorro can't cut through steel so he
takes it as a great opportunity to grow
as a swordsman there's some really cool
shots in this exchange too with Zorro
lifting a building but also flashbacks
into his past that lead him to reach
this state of power where he can
effectively hear everything or something
like that
ultimately the fight ends in his favor
having been able to on this occasion cut
through steel but not having mastered
this new state he's discovered and to
reiterate as I said before all of these
fights serve the story massively and not
only held my attention thoroughly but
they also entertain me furthering the
story of each of these characters
independent narratives in new and
interesting ways reinforcing for me my
appreciation and love for this ragtag
group of misfits and to think we haven't
even gotten to the good part yet the
climax when it comes to stories like
this one after having
so many convincing subversions were the
surprises that have left me overjoyed
while reading the ending is the moment
where the story makes or breaks itself
for many of us a lot of people when they
now think of Game of Thrones the first
thing that pops into their head is the
rushed ending and not the years of
quality writing that preceded it but
when it comes to this arc not only does
it stick the landing
it sets the standard immediately after
the straw hat crew achieved their goal
of taking out the respective targets in
a scene that is as compelling as it is
tense croc reveals in front of princess
Vivi and the king that he is
specifically after something called a
pond a cliff which only miss all Sunday
is able to read and will use it to point
her in the direction of something called
a pluton a massively powerful tool of
destruction he has been after since the
very start that would grant him the
power to destroy entire Islands in an
instant needless to say that's not good
but what's more is that in 30 minutes
it's revealed a massive cannon ball will
hit destroying a three-mile radius
starting at the city which achieves two
things narratively firstly it pains croc
as an even more insane psychopath lying
even to his baroque work subordinates
throwing them into the situation wherein
they won't survive
revealing to us that he trusts no one
but it also provides the straw hats with
a new goal find the bomb or person
setting off the bomb and stop it or them
at the source the goal of the crew and
the forces of good are in a constant
cycle of completion and renewal and
without a goal we the audience get kind
of bored so this is a fantastic way to
naturally extend the tension in the
series this helps keep the pace feeling
fresh and now that a time limit has been
put onto it it becomes all the more
suspenseful as we are at least I had no
idea how this was going to be resolved
and there are little things here and
there that fill my mind with wonder and
appreciation for this story like there's
this moment where Vivi convinces the
forces of the palace and the rebels to
stop fighting in an effort to evacuate
the city in time to make a significant
difference but croc says in passing so
so many chapters ago that he sends some
of his lesser forces to infiltrate the
ranks of both the palace guard and the
rebel forces and in calling back to that
the undercover baroque works members
within the battle continue the fighting
by shooting Koza inciting a massive riot
and once again the battle continues it's
spectacular
never saw it coming so what are they
gonna do now there's such a palpable
buildup of anticipation suspense despair
and tension with the rebellion going to
hell's or Oh gravely injured now after
his battle with mr. one a bomb about to
go off in like 15 minutes and no croc
apprehends princess Vivi dangling her
over a massive drop he lets her go it's
such an incredible buildup of tragedy
and now we as an audience have now
reached the lowest point we can go in
the story and so it's time to explode
once again with optimism
soaring through the air on the back of a
once thought to be dead Royal Guard pal
Luffy makes the save for princess Vivi
this is where the payoff for all the
time spent without Luffy comes flying in
to inject some much-needed light to this
dark situation but that's not to say the
tension is gone either we know how luffy
handled or didn't handle a croc the last
time and there's still only 15 minutes
left for him to win the day against one
is still one of the seven warlords of
the seat and as Luffy catches Vivi she
starts to break down similar to how Nami
did so during the hour-long park arc
Vivi has been trying everything in her
power to make the difference to save her
country her kingdom her people Vivi
grabs Luffy tightly her face slowly
crumbling before him she weeps over the
fact that no one can hear her that
everyone will die that everything will
be lost and that there's nothing they
can do Luffy simply responds
don't worry I can hear your voice what a
fantastic light and with that Luffy he
launches himself headfirst to croc zero
hesitation and thanks to the Yuba water
he brought on his back he's able to
cover himself head to toe Innes which
allows him to make contact with croc he
took the one piece of information
gleaned from his first fight and formed
an entire strategy around it and thus I
even my favorite part the symbolism here
is sensational uba's water allowed Luffy
to touch croc croc even mentioned during
the fight that Luffy didn't stand a
chance in this dry climate but what's
even better is that the water being used
symbolizes the trust of the king and the
love he had for his people and the love
they had for him the water from Yuba
wouldn't have been there had the old man
not believed in his country and his king
and now that loyalty and love that power
of alabasta is going to provide Luffy
the means with which to take out its
biggest faux crocodile I am
speech this with how well this all
placed together thigh matically and in
addition to that it also provides reason
as to why crock wanted specifically to
steal the rain from the country in the
first place to make himself more
powerful and to remove his weakness
entirely it wasn't just to frame the
king my god this is amazing on top of
that not only are crocks powers of sand
and dehydration great for a villain but
his motivations and decisions also
helped cement him as for me the absolute
best villain this series has shown us
thus far no contest
not even close don't add me and the
fight that ensues has some awesome
backhand forts in the form of Luffy
finally getting some great hits on him
Luffy drinking all the water and even a
particularly graphic scene that shows
Luffy completely dehydrated which he
manages to find a way out of using very
clever tactics and it's during this pair
of the arc things get more and more
serious as the straw hats barely managed
to find the bomb in time in a way that
is both light-hearted but also utilizes
everyone on the team leaving Vivi to be
the one to prevent it which I really
liked considering it's her story at the
end of the day however and unfortunately
for the straw crew it's revealed at the
bomb itself is on a timer
anyway as a contingency plan set by
crocodile but at the last second in what
was once again a moment I absolutely
didn't see coming
pail swoops down and sacrifices himself
for the kingdom and once again the way
it's paneled the way it's timed the way
it's carried out by Oda
I cried that's twice I've cried in this
arc so far and with that out of the way
Luffy just barely manages to take a croc
in what ends up being an incredibly
scrappy fight with Luffy even resorting
to use his own blood to hit crocodile
and if that wasn't enough the final
problem still remained they had to stop
the rebellion and what does Oh to do
with crocodiles defeat it begins to rain
once again over the kingdom because he
was the one preventing us bringing an
end to that long drought echoing the old
man's words once it rains the fighting
will end what a perfect finish to the
action that ties the choreography the
motivations the conflict and themes into
a big finish this arc has left me
utterly speechless on so many occasions
and it still has one left to get me with
and those of you that have seen this arc
you know what I'm gonna be talking about
and that's Vivi's goodbye at the end and
this was much more touching than I
thought it was going to be having
the entire saga with this character
through reverse Mountain whiskey peak
little garden drum island and now this
the alabaster Ark she's become a staple
of the crew but I think Oda made the
right decision ultimately by not making
her a full-time one and keeping her
where she wanted to be at her kingdom
reason being the one aspect of the straw
hat crew that ties them all together is
that they all share a dream that can be
fulfilled by traveling and exploring the
world as pirates Luffy wants to be the
pirate king zora wants to become the
greatest swordsman in the land nami
wants to map the world Sanji wants to
find the all blue who sup wants to
become a great warrior of the sea and
chopper wants to learn enough about
medicine to cure anything but princess
Vivi wanted to save her kingdom and know
she has and while I will miss her I
think the decision she ultimately makes
is a good one and if she had stayed we
wouldn't have gotten one of the best
send offs I've ever seen in any
character get in a series of any kind
with the X on their arm reminding Luffy
of a small but really nice moment
between the two in the early days of the
saga it definitely brought a tear to my
eye once again and left me with a
whirlwind of emotions to end what was
without an ounce of hyperbole the single
greatest manga reading experience of my
life Thank You Oda for writing this true
epic of a story and what makes this even
batteries that done it throughout this
story there have been little hints of
more to come and to expect in the story
specifically with the character of Miss
all Sunday who we learn is called Nico
Robin I didn't mention this in the
review but she saved Luffy after that
first fight with croc she betrayed him
and now at the very end wants to be one
of the straw hats so I have literally no
idea what to make of this but the
chaotic energy with which this story is
progressing and how vulnerable my
emotions feel with the slight danger
that the Falls each of these characters
I've become now incredibly attached to
is a sign that I will be in for a very
rough ride I'm sure with this arc now
done I suppose the goal now is to
continue down the chain of islands until
we reached the end taking care of every
subsequent warlord of the sea I wonder
if white beard is a warlord one thing
that really bothers me is that dude that
controls the weather with the tattoo in
his face I don't have the first idea
where he fits into all of this and don't
even get me started on the
misunderstanding A's had on drum island
looking for Luffy or Blackbeard I don't
want to say I think time travel is
involved but it feels like it might be
or that people broadly speaking are
using
though if they think that Blackbeard is
gone and in addition to that I'm really
excited to see how Robin plays a role
into all of this she definitely doesn't
feel like a good guy character right now
but is definitely distinct enough from
the rest of them to make a very
interesting crew member if nothing else
but with that all finally done this is
where the alabaster Ark ends and where
my review ends
tune in next week when I'll be reviewing
Jaya and the Skype yarks info I honestly
can't wait to see what's to come but as
always I've been totally nut mark I'll
see you all next week and thank you so
much for watching
[Music]